bonsoir à tous bonsoir série mercy de
cette date prêter à ceux
à ce petit passage sur le grill puisque
ça va être ça l'idée alors bien que je
sois de très loin le plus âgé des deux
on va commencer cet échange grand-père a
contenu une histoire grand père est en
toi et en l'occurrence l'idée c'était de
faire un retour d'expérience sur la
convention citoyenne
et citoyen pour le climat et de voir
quels enseignements on peut en tirer sur
ce qui marche et marche moins bien dans
notre système démocratique on va dire
quand il s'agit de prendre en
considération des enjeux de long terme
ça fait longtemps qu'il ya des gens qui
se grattent la tête les uns disent il
faudrait faire une chambre et autres
spécialistes du long terme les autres
vice premier ministre on était
en fait on sent bien pour patton autour
de cette idée qui est qui est d'essayer
type en un peu autrement la première
question que j'aurai les tout bête c'est
quoi la genèse du projet ça commence
truc là est menée à qui il a fallu en
parler pour que ça va et j'ai une
question incidente qui est qu est ce qui
fait qu macron à accepter et à ton avis
pour placer à mon avis qu'est-ce que lui
pensait que ça allait lui amener comme
bénéfices puisque ce genre d'animal
accepte rarement quelque chose sans
penser que ça va lui amener un bénéfice
et bonsoir jean marc je m'en sors tout
le monde d'être là
écoute ce truc est né dans la continuité
des mobilisations pour le climat qui ont
commencé en 2018 quand nicolas hulot a
démissionné et a eu une sorte de
succession de
d'acteurs qui ont commencé à se
rejoindre donc ça a commencé par les
marches pour le climat en septembre
ensuite il ya eu
les jeunes autour de greta thoune berg
etc qui ont commencé leur grève pour le
climat
puis à peu près de façon concomitante il
ya eu le démarrage de l'extinction
global yen à londres est quasiment le
même week-end le démarrage des gilet
jaune en france
et
moi j'ai fait partie des personnes qui
ont essayé de faire se rejoindre ces
différentes
mais ces différentes marches ces
différents mouvements de contestation
donc j'avais écrit une tribune dans libé
au
début décembre 2018 pour appeler les
gilet jaune à marcher avec nous en
disant que finalement le problème qui a
été la source à la fois de du
déséquilibre climatique et des
inégalités se trouvait certainement dans
un modèle économique qui considéraient
que le monde était un vaste gisement de
ressources et que les humains étaient
des variables d'ajustement est pas
du vivant avec lequel
on a des égards ajusté comme dirait
baptiste morisod
et petit à petit à force
tout ça a fini par construire un rapport
de force le mouvement des filets jaunes
ayant une composante assez musclé
d'action directe qui s'est mis à mettre
le flou sous caisse ça commence à
devenir assez tendue et par dessus tout
ça est arrivé la sphère du siècle donc
le l'idée d'attaquer l'état en justice
pour ne pas avoir fait assez pour
protéger la population française face
aux dangers du changement climatique il
se trouve que pour la faire du siècle on
avait réuni énormément d'acteurs que ce
soit des ong des personnalités publiques
acteurs chanteurs des influenceurs ou
youtube heure où je sais pas comment il
faut les appeler des mouvements citoyens
et
on avait raconté une histoire qui à mon
sens avait toutes les chances de plaire
aux français puisque s'il s'agissait
d'attaqués les d'injustice car la
bagarre
et il se trouve qu'on s'est pas trompé
parce que en quelques jours on a atteint
un million de signatures pour attaquer
les pins justice et on a moins on était
à 2 millions 3 ce qui était ce qui est
lui toujours le record de mobilisation
en ligne en france du coup on est invité
sur france inter pour en parler et
on y va marion cotillard et moi parce
qu'on était de figure que les gi truc on
critique la politique d' emmanuel macron
et quelques jours plus tard marion
m'appelle et me dit est ce que tu as
reçu le texto de macron un jeu différent
parce que moi j'ai pas tellement de
textos de mâcon en général dans ma vie
mais mes et toi qu'est ce que c'est
moins cher sur un texte au cinéma la con
mais je ne sais pas si c'est le vrai
plein de copains qui écrivent en signant
mcqueen détrompe toi je pouvais avoir
des copains qui peuvent faire ça qu'elle
m'envoie le texto je lui dis dans ma
prime et si le je pense que c'est le
vrai macron donc je lui rédige une
petite réponse qu'elle lui envoie
quelques semaines plus tard il lui
proposant vont devenir à l'elysée pour
lui expliquer que ouais on n'a pas bien
compris que la politique française pour
le climat c'est formidable et qu' il se
fera un plaisir de lui décrire toutes
les mesures qui sont prises donc elle
elle dit moi je veux pas y aller tout
seul donc on y va tous les deux et moi
je m'étais dit à quoi ça sert à ça me
faisait
ça m'intéressait d'un point de vue
anthropologique on va dire de montrer la
berge
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs
mais au-delà de ça je me disais à quoi
ça si c'est juste pour que voilà il ya
des photos un serrage de main et qu ils
se servent de nous pour faire croire
qu'il fait quelque chose ça sert à rien
donc on a exigé que la rencontre soit
privé
ils ont essayé de nous la faire à
l'envers juste avant et puis on a menacé
pas venir finalement donc c'est resté
privé et j'avais constamment juste un
élément de compréhension privé ça veut
dire sans communiquer de 13 100
conseillers ou non ça veut dire pas de
queue s'est pas inscrit à l'agenda bas
grands bénéficiaires ok donc qu'il n'ya
pas de photo et donc qu'il n'ya pas de
communication publique qui est à
quelques jours de la rencontre c'est
totalement officieux
et pendant la rencontre
il démarre deux comme il fait c'est à
dire bon y sert la main avec le sourire
jusqu'aux dents il fait de petites
références de petites allusions à quand
est ce que quand on s'était vus la fois
d'avant salon du livre pour créer un
truc de de familiarité il commence par
dire mon j'ai quelques idées sur les
territoires et sage jeudi
si ça vous ennuie pas est-ce qu'on peut
prendre cinq dix minutes pour faire une
sorte de point de la situation pour
qu'on se dise où on en est qu'on essaie
de parler sur un terrain commun parce
que là si c'est juste pour parler de des
quelques idées qu'on a sur les
territoires je crois que c'est pas on
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur du sujet
et et bio est bien sûr très bien et
finalement en fait j'ai parlé 45 minutes
sans m'arrêter
quasiment il avait préparé toute une
sorte de
argumentaire donc d'abord je lui avais
apporté les dernières études qui
montrent l accélération du processus et
le fait que voilà on allait vers une
trajectoire de hauts cadres je lui avais
apporté des rapports qui avaient des
produits notamment l'onu qui dans son
rapport soutenabilité avait commandé un
rapport à un cabinet finlandais pour
demander si le capitalisme était en
mesure de nous sortir de là ou pas et le
cabinet finlandais avait dit non après
pas dans les temps impartis parce que
d'ici 2030 fallait les les impératifs de
rentabilité financière sans trop à court
terme et c'est c'est pas compatible avec
les activités qu'on aurait besoin de
développer qui elles sont pas forcément
directement
rémunératrices en tout cas pas à ce
point là je lui avais apporté le rapport
de belles évolutions la cave essayé de
traduire le l'objectif de 5 degrés pour
voir ce que ça donnerait dans des
mesures prises par le gouvernement
français évidemment il y avait des trucs
du style réduire de 50% le nombre de
voitures en circulation
faire une tombola pour savoir qui peut
prendre l'avion sont passés de 90 kg de
viande à 25 et donc après avoir empilé
ça je lui dis on est bien d'accord que
ça vous ne le ferez jamais vous le ferez
pas c'est sûr et puis vous le ferez pas
en plus parce que ça se trouve vous
auriez la moitié de la france dans la
rue enfin si vous dites il faut qu'on
est debout et moins de voitures il me
dit ah oui oui on est d'accord je ne
ferai pas je dis donc je pense que la
seule solution pour y arriver puisque
vous ne ferez pas que vous avez des
forces économiques qui en plus font
pression sur vous que vous avez
l'inertie de votre administration
c'est de remettre la chose entre les
mains des français c'est-à-dire de tirer
des gens au sort de leur proposer de se
saisir du sujet d'être alimentée par des
experts qui leur expliquent tous les
tenants et les aboutissants de les faire
délibérer à ciel ouvert pour que tout le
monde puisse suivre l'état de leurs
réflexions et qu'ensuite
le fruit de leurs délibérations et leurs
couleurs leurs propositions soient
soumises à référendum et donc avait déjà
participé à une conférence des citoyens
jeu mais en fait j'avais j'avais été
filmée
ce qui s'était passé en islande au
moment où il avait eu le krach en 2009
10 il avait réécrit la constitution il
avait élu un petit panel de citoyens
pour bon tout ce processus avait été
d'ailleurs jusqu'au bout
le seul problème étant qu'il y avait un
référendum consultatif pour valider la
nouvelle constitution qui n'était que
consultatif il est conservateur qui
était au pouvoir décider de le laisser
consultative et puis je connaissais bien
l'exemple irlandais qui avaient utilisé
des conventions citoyenne pour
travailler sur le droit à l'avortement
et le mariage pour tous qui étaient deux
points durs dans la société irlandaise
très catholique et qui avait réussi à
faire évoluer ces deux points grâce à la
convention citoyenne qui paie ce qui
avait été suivie de référendum et puis
j'avais beaucoup échangé avec david
vendrait groupe qui a écrit un livre
passionnant qui s'appelle contre les
élections où il fait une sorte de voyage
pour regarder quelles sont les
innovations démocratiques les plus
intéressantes un peu partout
et donc cette idée là que je le lui
proposait on l'avait déjà mise dans la
presse avec un collectif qui s'appelle
et j les citoyens le 30 janvier en dix
ans le grand débat ça nous paraît
paraître les ovations démocratique du
siècle parce que c'est emmanuel
maintenant qui va parler pendant des
heures des gens dans les villes je
connais un peu parce que j'ai participé
à ce genre d'exercice je vois très bien
les which we do donc la libé c'était
vraiment de lui dire et j'étais très
insistant il m'a fait reformuler et
soudain
il m'a dit ce que vous me dites c'est
que les citoyens produisent des choses
est directement je les passe au
référendum sans les modifier je dis oui
c'est simple idée d'accord ok j'ai pigé
bon
[Musique]
et ensuite il m'a dit il nous a dit bon
donner moins huit jours pour voir si on
y arrive on fête les 10 joueurs sont
devenus deux mois et puis bon finalement
il c'est lui qui a remis le truc sur le
papier a priori contre l'avis de son
administration et qui a décidé de le
faire je pense que le bénéfice qu'ils
pensaient en tirer c'était et c'est un
peu ce que j'avais si l'on dira que je
lui ai fait miroiter le fait qu'il avait
une occasion historique d'être un vrai
leader qui rentre dans l'histoire qui
fait quelque chose à la fois sur le plan
climatique et démocratique qui n'a
jamais été fait
aucun endroit du monde est donc bon ce
genre de personnage aime bien aussi ce
type de ce type de perspective de faire
quelque chose qui entend l'histoire mais
je crois aussi que il n'avait pas mesuré
à quel point les citoyens à les pousser
loin l'exercice à quel point leur
proposition serait ambitieuse à quel
point ça ferait réagir dans la société
et à quel point ils allaient se
retrouver
tenu même si au final il a fait ce qu'il
a voulu mais tenue un peu par sa parole
en tout cas dans les médias c'est à dire
qu'on lui en demanderait des comptes et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a et que
c'était un de mes rôle de garant d'être
extrêmement
tenace sur cette idée du sans filtre
parce que comme c'est un prostitué un
processus qui n'est pas
institutionnaliser ultime ans c'est
vraiment le président de la république a
le dernier mot donc il n'y a que lui qui
pouvait nous assurer qu'on irait
jusqu'au bout donc c'est pour cette idée
du sans-fil servi à ça elle servait à ce
que les mesures qui allaient être
élaborée par les citoyens ne repasse pas
par la moulinette
et de l'administration et des lobbys bon
réalité ça s'est quand même fait
mais bon on a réussi à ce que ça existe
on a réussi à le faire à peu près
comment voulez le faire ça qu'on a
réussi à faire travailler les citoyens
dans des vraiment dans de très bonnes
conditions et pour moi on a réussi à
faire la démonstration que quand on
propose à des citoyens qui qui qui n'ont
pas d'intérêt particulier au premier
chef
series ont pas intérêt électoral non pas
l'intérêt économique dans cette affaire
on leur donne vraiment les éléments pour
se faire une idée qu'on leur propose de
se mettre au service de l'intérêt
général
non seulement ils font du bon travail
vraiment un travail de bonne qualité
mais en plus un travail et des
propositions qui vont beaucoup plus loin
que ce que les élus ont fait ces 20 ou
ces trente dernières années j'en ai
parlé longuement là puisque j'ai
interviewé pour un autre truc que je
veux voir s'appelle hélène landes mort
qui est qui professeur à à yale aux
états unis qui est professeur de
sciences politiques et particulièrement
spécialiste de la démocratie et d
innovation démocratique qui a suivi la
convention citoyenne de base qui a même
organisé ensuite un congrès avec des
spécialistes du monde entier sur la
question parce qu'elle elle trouve que
c'est effectivement une innovation
démocratique
majeur enfin passionnante qui évidemment
n'a pas pu aller à son terme mais qui en
tout cas porte en lui les germes de
quelque chose qui mériterait d'être
reproduits et elle me disait vraiment
pour moi c'est c'est une des voix qui
nous permettraient de d'être
véritablement démocratie ce qu'elle
disait je j'insiste bien sur le fait que
l enseigne elle qu'elle enseigne les
sciences politiques que c'est pas du
tout une radicale que c'est quelqu'un
qui m'aime dans un milieu relativement
bourgeois et stains et qui s'appuie sur
les recherches les plus récentes
notamment cette fameuse étude de martin
and games la de 2014 qui a été publié
chez oxford princeton est ce
qui montre bien que dans nos sociétés
occidentales
en réalité
on est plutôt dans des formes
d'oligarchie ou deux plutôt qu racine
c'est-à-dire de dans des systèmes où les
10% les plus riches ont une influence
démesurée sur les décisions publiques et
donc ces femmes cette fameuse étude de
martina hingis en fait ils ont étudié
plus de 2000 décision publique sur
quinze ou vingt ans aux états unis en
essayant justement de se faire une idée
de des éléments moteurs et qui avaient
le plus d'influencé dans la société et
pour eux c'était absolument sans
équivoque c'est à dire que pour 80 % des
décisions publiques s'étaient
majoritairement l'élite et l'élite
économique
les plus grandes entreprises ou les
personnes qui ont la surface financière
la plus importante qui ont influencé ces
décisions-là
la population elle même est relativement
réduite à
voter tous les cinq ans tous les 6 ans
tous les quatre ans casoni et dans
l'intervalle a relativement peu de poids
relativement peu d'initiatives pour
pouvoir ou proposer des lois ou des
avancées ou s'opposer à un certain
nombre de dispositions aller dans la rue
faire des pétitions mais tout ça on voit
bien que ça a de moins en moins d'impact
est donc là quand je parlais avec elle
et je finis avec ça c'était très
intéressant c'est que je lui posais la
question en tant que spécialiste de la
démocratie pour toi qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qui pose problème par rapport à la
question démocrate la question
climatique s'il ya pourquoi nos
démocraties n'arrive pas à gérer la
question climatique de façon beaucoup
plus puissante je dis bien le problème
c'est que c'est que nous ne vivons pas
vraiment dans des démocraties tient que
là le pouvoir du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple c'est pas vraiment ça
pour le moment et donc on se heurte
effectivement à des intérêts économiques
qui n'ont pas forcément à court terme en
tout cas envie que des modifications
aussi radicale et lieu et c'est
clairement ce qui nous est arrivé avec
la convention si tony g par une question
le pouvoir par le peuple et pour le
peuple est ce qu il soit s'exercerait
exactement de la même manière si on
avait affaire à un peuple qui n'était
pas passée barre de deux cases qui sont
d'une part la formation et d'autre part
quelque part l'obligation et même
l'acceptation puisque je crois que ce
qui pouvait faire ce qu'ils voulaient a
refusé et pouvait refuser donc en fait
les j'ai envie de dire les plus
mauvaises têtes ou les peut-être les
plus hostiles je sais pas il y en a
quand même une partie qui ne sont pas à
leur part majoritaire mais qui ce qui
n'était pas d'un dispositif met donc en
fait que ça c'était une question que
j'avais cet avis mais j'ai quand même la
question est ce que m est ce que dans
les élément très structurant de ce genre
de processus il n'ya pas d'une part la
formation
donc le fait de le fait de réaliser ce
qui se passe et donc il ya une carence
médiatique aussi que ce genre de
dispositif combler n'y a pas juste une
carence institutionnels et d'autre part
le fait de devoir travailler de manière
collective
dans un contexte dans lesquelles les
gens l'acceptent et du coup on se
retrouve pas seul face à l'angoissé face
à face aux défis et ça libère quand même
de l'audace et de l' envie de faire que
les gens n'ont pas quand ils sont seuls
dans leur coin ou que les cercles
sociaux dans lesquels se soient inscrits
sont des cercles pour rien à voir avec
le problème à traiter qu'est ce que ces
deux éléments là sont quand même pas
deux éléments qui jouent de manière très
très forte et qui sont pas deux éléments
qui expliquent notamment comment est-ce
qu'une bande de français ordinaires
transport en écolo militants qui vont
jusqu'à faire peur aux présidents
quelque part
si complètement et d'ailleurs dans tous
les éléments qui permettraient d'aller
vers une démocratie plus ouvertes
c'est-à-dire une démocratie où où les
citoyens ont beaucoup plus d'initiatives
il est clair qu'il ya des processus de
d'apprentissage et de
la démocratie ça s'apprend dire qu'on
passe pas deux je vote tous les cinq ans
et je m'en occupe pas sauf pour aller
manifester ou à faire des pétitions à je
m'implique sans un certain nombre
d'étapes et il est clair que
[Musique]
moi je pense que ce qui fonctionne très
bien c'est une sorte d'hybridation entre
ce qu'on a fait avec la convention
citoyenne est ce qu'on peut connaître en
suisse c'est que des citoyens puissent
avoir l'initiative de mettre un sujet
sur le tapis donc ce qui est est ce
qu'on appelle référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
présentation en suisse où m pour la
votation en suisse où l'initiative
européenne qui existent aussi donc il
faut déterminer quel est le pourcentage
du corps électoral qui doit se mobiliser
pour pouvoir obliger le parlement à se
saisir et le gouvernement se saisir d'un
sujet
ensuite ce sujet pour moi devrait être
examinée par des personnes tirées au
sort qu'on va former effectivement donc
ils vont avoir un temps de formation et
je pense que ça pourrait même être
encore plus élaborée que ce qu'on a fait
pour la convention citoyenne où on a été
très vite sur un juge un sujet qui en
plus est très complexe avec vraiment
énormément de dimension et qui aurait
mérité d'être approfondies et d'avoir un
temps de digestion beaucoup plus
important et une phase de délibération
et ça c'est ce que tu disais quand tu
désires mais ont fait ensemble on est
obligé de faire ensemble on a vu à quel
point la délibération était un outil
extraordinaire pour
construire du consensus pour permettre à
des gens qui ne sont absolument pas
d'accord au départ ou qui n'ont pas des
idées politiques similaires de trouver
un terrain d'entente qui n'est pas
forcément celui de l'ain ou celui de
l'autre mais c'était c'était très
impressionnant de voir à quel point par
exemple les idées on pourrait qualifier
de complotiste ou en tout cas de
vraiment très extrêmes très farfelues
était assez rapidement écartée par le
groupe ça tu vas situe à assister à
l'ensemble des débats ou wayne quasiment
à l'ensemble des débats ouais j'ai dû
rater un accord parce que j'étais en
tournage mais sinon j'étais là en
octobre donc pas vraiment assisté à tout
et c'était très impressionnant de voir
ça de voir que il y avait il y avait une
espèce d'équilibré qui se faisait en
groupe parce que il y en a toujours un
cas un peu plus d'expertisé sur un sujet
un autre qui va pouvoir dire mais
attendez si on prend telle mesure moi
par exemple dans ma vie ça marche pas du
tout ça et un autre va pouvoir sur
enchaîné et donc ça finit par construire
une sorte de terrain commun et comme il
n'y a pas encore une fois d'intérêts
particuliers trop fort chercher personne
n'a vraiment intérêt à tirer la
couverture à lui a rien à gagner à la
fin c'est vraiment se mettre au service
de l'intérêt général comme on le ferait
dans un juré d'assises où on vient et
pendant un temps donné on se saisit d'un
problème et on doit essayer de prendre
la décision la plus juste possible le
fait d'être observé le fait aussi de
d'avoir été missionné et c'est ça qui a
été assez cruel d'ailleurs dans la
convention citoyenne c'est que je pense
que un bon nombre de citoyens se sentent
vraiment senti investi d'une mission
parce que a à l'issue de leurs travaux
il y avait un débouché tangible on leur
a dit oui si vos propositions sont
suffisamment abouti quelles sont sous
forme de projet de loi elles passeront
sans filtre
c'est quand même un sacré truc c'est
très rare de proposer à des citoyens
d'aller aussi loin dans l'élaboration de
la loi donc là tout d'un coup c'était du
sérieux et pour moi c'est ça qui fait
évidemment défaut à tous les processus
de démocratie participative qui sont
pour moi des très souvent des simulacres
de 2,2 de participation parce que on
fait semblant de demander son avis à des
gens et puis en réalité on a déjà une
idée très arrêtée ce qu'on veut faire
moi je les fais
comme ça c'est les débats publics ben
tiens j'ai bien connu
n'est jamais arrivé plein de fois le
surveiller avec des villes qui me disent
bon alors voilà on veut faire participer
les gens pour le plan climat le connaît
déjà les six points comment on fait pour
qu'ils y arrivent sépare c'est partout
pareil c'est en tout paris j'ai donc
donc là c'est pas pareil et c'est ça en
fait qui est aussi un an 7 janvier j'ai
mis très longtemps à comprendre qu'ils
avaient une haie d'une superbe novlangue
dans les procédures françaises qui
s'appelle le débat sur l'utilité
publique
donc en fait quand j'étais jeune et
qu'on l'ait maintenant je suis devenu
vieux et qu'on me dise mes enfants je je
je croyais qu'on allait discuter de
l'utilité de faire et en fait c'est pas
du tout ça pour qu'on discute dans les
objectifs
c'est de la manière de rajouter trois
amendements un truc qu'on a décidé de
faire
voilà pourquoi les gens veulent c'est ça
qui est quand même très intéressant
c'est que
les gens sont quand même pas idiot donc
ou d'un moment et je le vois ça ce qui
s'est passé que le grand débat il voit
aussi que quand il vote pour quelqu'un
ça change pas fondamentalement leur vie
et que ça résout pas non plus des
problèmes majeurs donc au bout d'un
moment c'est normal qu'ils aient une
forme de fracture qui me forme de
désintérêt de la politique il ya un
désintérêt du vote cueillez un désamour
des responsables politiques c est ce qu
on a découvert là parce qu'on a re
découvert parce qu'on l'avait vu à
d'autres occasions c'est que y'a pas du
tout un désintérêt de la politique au
sens propre il dira que encore une fois
quand tu te donne la possibilité aux
gens de simples et et de et de vraiment
bosser parce qu'ils savent que ça va
servir à quelque chose et c'est vraiment
ça la clé c'est quand ils savent que ça
va servir à quelque chose
yvon et je dire ils ont bossé neuf mois
et week-end et même entre les sessions
il continuer à bosser et continuent à se
parler des ateliers c'est quand même
impressionnant de voir le la dévotion
coiffe un jeu l'engagement désintéressé
que tu peux trouver chez des citoyens
sur des sujets encore une fois aussi
complexe aussi grave aussi et puis aussi
casse-gueule parce qu' il fallait y
arriver quand même j'ai deux questions
alors il ya une question sur
l'organisation de la formation parce
qu'en fait la formation à un moment
c'est accepter de remettre
un tiers de confiance c'est à dire les
organisateurs de la convention et les
gens qui vont venir le fait d'avoir une
vision du monde qui est suffisante pour
être capable de discuter du problème
qu'on va traiter derrière comment est-ce
que cette confiance mais c'est voilà
est-ce que et j'ai eu une deuxième
question alors qu'il est pendant qu'ils
aient est ce que un certain nombre ont
considéré qu'il y avait on ne savait
jamais assez
comment est-ce qu'ils ont pris
finalement l' équilibre entre on peut
pas y passer 25 ans est par ailleurs
quand on rentre dans un sujet est
terriblement complexe avec des
ramifications dans tous les sens et qui
en fait ont fini assez vite par le
comprendre en barque à peu près tout ce
qu'on fait partout et tout le temps
où est-ce qu'on pose la limite pour en
savoir assez et avoir confiance dans son
propre jugement d'accord comment ça
c'est gérer ça ben c'est pas facile
il y avait un équilibre à trouver entre
leur donner des informations qui étaient
le consensus scientifique sur la
question climatique par exemple
le plus communément admis donc on leur a
donné dans le ce qu'on avait appelé là
c'est plus que mon humble c'est la base
de connaissance ou un don qui était à la
fois un document écrit
et
quelques interventions
dit le giec ce que dit le haut conseil
pour les questions les citoyens eux
mêmes ont été associés à leur programme
de formation au point de formation il a
été décidé par le comité d'organisation
ils ont été ils ont été un peu associés
se dire qu'un corps mais la base c'est
pas un point d'amélioration ça quelque
part est absolument c'est d'ailleurs une
vraie conversation qu'on a eue avec une
fois à quel événement qui me dit si on
veut vraiment faire en sorte que ces
assemblées citoyennes soit le plus
démocratique possible il faut arriver à
ce qu'elles soient pas piloté par un
comité de gouvernance qui lui même va
induire des choses va potentiellement
arrêtez enfin bord d un certain nombre
de débats ou de processus ce qui n'était
pas inutile là pour cette fois là parce
que c'était une première et que je pense
que c'est encore une fois sur un sujet
aussi vaste je pense qu'ils avaient
besoin de cadres pour démarrer mais
idéalement oui il faudrait que le groupe
soit capable de s'auto saisir de plus en
plus de sa propre formation est donc là
il y avait 1 une partie du socle de
connaissances qui était vraiment apporté
par le comité de gouvernance mais en
essayant d'aller vers la plus grande
objectivité possible sur la qualité des
informations dont comprenant des
informations qui étaient vraiment
admise par les institutions par le le
consensus scientifique
donc on s'était aussi valérie masson
delmotte qui vient donc 10 président
d'un des groupes de travail du giec et
ce terrain
ça c'était une chose après il y avait
leur donner
un certain nombre de points de vue
différents qui venaient de différents
acteurs de la société qui n'était pas
du même horizon donc ça le but c'était
d'avoir une plus une pluralité dire
qu'il parle à la fois des ong à la fois
à des chefs d'entreprises dont il ya eu
le patron d'adp et p
louis gallois le patron psa mais il ya
eu aussi des agriculteurs bio mais il ya
eu aussi des architectes mais il ya eu
aussi points mais il ya eu aussi
des des syndicalistes comme laurent
bergé ils ont auditionné des politiques
en exercice donc des ministres des
anciens ministres
pour essayer de faire un tour d'horizon
et ça c'était un de nos rôles c'était le
comité de gouvernance et les garants de
veiller à la pluralité la plus
importante possible de ces points 2
ensuite on leur a demandé de nous dire
qu'ils le voudraient auditionné donc on
a ouvert une liste et ils ont là ils ont
avancé à faire un peu leur shopping list
inscrire des noms et donc ont appris les
noms qui revenait le plus souvent et on
a organisé quelque chose qui était aussi
un endroit où il avait du choix c'était
une espèce de speed dating c'est à dire
qu'il y avait dix tables avec 10
personnes et toutes les 40 minutes ça
changeait et donc il pouvait choisir la
table où il allait en fonction du sujet
qui les intéressait le plus et puis ils
pouvaient aller de l'une à l'autre pour
essayer de leur donner encore une fois
un maximum de connaissances clairement
leur ressenti c'est que ça allait vite
qu'ils avaient énormément de choses à
avaler que parfois c'était indigeste que
c'était trop et que
ils ont eu des moments de découragement
en cause des ans mais
c'est trop lassés trop en arrière un pas
comment on va faire pour intégrer tout
ça et puis ce qui a fini par
par les aider à métaboliser une fois
encore ces groupes c'est à dire que
ans en parlant en acceptant aussi que
basa est pas tout retenu mais que c'est
pas grave parce qu'il y en avait
d'autres qui était un peu plus fort sur
tel ou tel sujet qu'il y avait aussi des
bases écrite qui pouvaient retourner
voir des vidéos bon ils ont accepté en
fait de faire avec ce qu'ils pouvaient
et puis il avait un autre
un autre soutien on va dire qu'il était
le groupe d'appui dans qui était avec
des avec des experts que là aussi on a
essayé prendre dans des structures qui
était reconnu par tout le monde et qui
étaient les plus belles et les plus plus
objectif possible et les plus
spécialistes possible de leur domaine
qui étaient là pour les aider dans quand
ils prenaient leurs mesures pour leur
dire bon il ya déjà ça qu'ils existent
si vous faites ça ça va avoir un tel
impact si vous faites ça bah ça pourrait
en avoir peut-être un peu moins donc
réfléchissons bien aussi avec ces
données là et donc ce qui l'inquiétait
pas facile c'est que pour un sujet aussi
complexe qui allait si vite le poids de
ce groupe d'appui était très important
bien que la proposition qui a été faite
par le groupe d'appui avaient tendance à
être un peu
adopt a adopté mais en tout cas servir
de base de façon très rapide aux
citoyens parce qu'ils sont pas
spécialistes de domaines oui c'est à
dire que c'est le dialogue classique en
tant que citoyen à l'extérieur certains
experts il a quand même enfin l'expert
quand il est investi de la confiance est
là il arrive dans un cadre investi de la
confiance il a nécessairement un
avantage confirmé dans son contenu
difficile d'y échapper et donc là
c'était un autre job est
particulièrement nous les gars en deux
de tout le temps redire aux citoyens
attention ça c'est un point de vue c'est
une proposition
ensuite vous en faites ce que vous
voulez c'est pas du tout obligé de
suivre cette ligne là vous pouvez faire
autrement et donc ça les a aidés est
effectivement un des moments à
s'affranchir de ce que les que les
groupes d'appui leur proposer et puis ça
a aussi fait que le groupe d'appui
rester très à distance et pour le coup
ils ont quand même été vraiment super
parce qu'ils l'auront toujours
donner les informations en disant je
vous donne la formation technique
maintenant je fais gaffe de prendre deux
pas de recul et s'il le faisait pas on
leur tomber quand même sur le rap
c'était pas parfait mais c'était quand
même plutôt réussi et plutôt sincère en
tout cas dans le travail de que chacun
puisse le lien avec le projet de loi il
a existé et c'est à dire les citoyens
ont directement discuté avec des gens
qui ont fait le projet de loi ou bien il
n'y a pas eu de contact direct et donc
le projet de loi s'est inspiré de la
copie rendue par les citoyens mais sans
discussion c'est si un certain nombre de
citoyens qui ont été conviés par le
ministère la transition écologique
particulièrement à faire des débats avec
les les entreprises concernées et puis
ils ont été auditionnés par le sénat et
l'assemblée un certain d'entre eux
mais ça j'ai envie de te dire cesser
c'était pas dans le contrat c'est à dire
que oui bien sûr théoriquement mais
c'était même un problème dire que
théoriquement le les citoyens avaient
déjà discuté avec tous ces gens ou en
tout cas une partie d'entre eux à partir
de ces discussions avaient fait des
propositions et ses propositions étaient
suffisamment bien formulé pour pouvoir
aller directement à l'assemblée ou au
référendum donc être tranchée en gros
par la représentation populaire ou par
le peuple français directement faire ce
qu'il faut faire ce qui a été fait c'est
à dire les remettent dans le chaudron
est très souvent ils se sont retrouvés
en minorité face à un certain nombre de
deux pas de patrons d'entreprises qui
leur disaient non mais c'est n'importe
quoi votre truc c'est inapplicable ça va
créer tant de chômeurs
ça les a mis dans une position
extrêmement inconfortable en plus
souvent ils étaient un petit groupe
séparé du reste des 150 or les décisions
avaient été prises par les 150 donc de
toutes façons il ne pouvait pas revenir
dessus je dire le vote avait déjà été
fait et il n'avait pas de légitimité
pour revenir dessus et donc ça a été une
façon de leur faire un peut avaler la
pilule du détricotage d'un certain
nombre de leurs propositions par l'
influence des intérêts privés est
arrivé à ce projet de loi qui est
effectivement inspiré de leur 149
propositions mais qui en a écarté une
bonne partie qui en a minimisé la plus
grande partie et qui du coup a un impact
infiniment moindre que ce qui était
leur valeur travail initial j'ai deux
questions la première c est ce que sur
les 149 propositions qu'ils étaient
convaincus que c'était la chose à faire
où il était convaincu que c'était une
proposition à discuter
je pense pas qu'ils étaient convaincus
que c'était la seule chose à faire en
revanche
ils ont vraiment essayé de construire un
projet qui s'étonnait c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient six groupes de travail
qui étaient sur les sujets majeurs des
différents différents tenants et
aboutissants du problème climatique et
ils ont vraiment réfléchi les choses de
façon transversale pour qu'elles se
répondent et ils ont voulu faire en
sorte que que tout ça fasse un ensemble
cohérent qui était qui était vraiment
pensé pour être 1 transformation de
société et donc il était tout à fait
prêt à
soumettre sainte dire qu'il était tout à
fait prêt à ce que les députés
revault enfin ça c'est des amendements à
ce qu' il ya référendum éventuellement
un choix multiple et que les français
puissent décider vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'avoir écrit
le texte sacré mais en revanche s'il
avait l'impression que tout ça se tenait
et que c'était pas non plus le
supermarché c'est pas à la casse parce
qu'une des questions moi que je que je
me suis posée c'est de savoir si macron
ces familles dans un corner avec son
idée de reprendre sans filtre dit
autrement quand des gens travaillent il
me semble que le minimum qu'on leur doit
c'est d'avoir en face des gens qui
suivent qui suivent l'évolution des
travaux
sans nécessairement intervenir mais qui
sont capables de comprendre ce qui est
en train de se passer qui découvre pas
le truc juste à la fin avec son
engouement d'effroi soit un
applaudissement des quatre mains et qui
est justement une capacité de
discussions derrière mais dans un esprit
constructif
or là j'imagine que lui il a absolument
pas suivi les travaux pendant les
travaux je sais pas s'il avait un
émissaire qui était chargé de le faire
faire une émission plutôt une bande des
viscères parce que tous suivent une
bande qui était chargé de suivre en
temps réel de belles sorte qu'à la fin
j'ai l'impression qu'il s'est retrouvé
un peu comme une comme une poule devant
un couteau qu'il avait un objet qui
n'avait pas bien vu arriver et donc il
savait pas trop quoi faire
on et ça c'est sûr et d'ailleurs une
partie de ses conseillers a été assez
pas folle et cette promesse du son
filtre qui qu'il trouvait être une
promesse exorbitantes ski et qui de
toute façon ne pouvait pas être tenu et
c'est un problème d'ailleurs nous mêmes
on a quand même beaucoup oeuvré pour que
ils prennent cet engagement là encore
une fois parce qu'on n'avait pas
d'autres on avait rien d'autre dans la
main quoi c'était notre seul levier mais
pour autant le fait d'avoir promis
quelque chose qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
tenir et a priori s'il pas idiot il le
savait dès le départ c'est encore un
coup de couteau dans le contrat
démocratique avec les avec les français
c'est encore une
une fois de plus on se dit bon ben voilà
leur parole ne vaut rien donc ça c'est
quand même un sujet mais quant à savoir
s'il ya des gens qui suivaient oui
particulièrement au ministère de la
transition écologique
mais pour autant une fois d'ailleurs il
y avait eu une fille qui était membre du
comité de gouvernance qui était dans le
canal
pour autant quand ils ont vu arriver
149 proposition et savez bien français
si c'était à refaire aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que tu dirais nature président
en termes de moyens que l'état aurait dû
mettre pour que la courroie de
transmission ce parce que c'est
respectueux lui aurait dit je veux voir
trois personnes de bercy personne du
ministère de l'agriculture etc et je
veux qu'il soit dans l'hémicycle tous
les jours la suit les dissuade qu'est-ce
que tu demanderais que tu n'as pas pensé
à demander à l'époque lecture faite en
fait une chose qu'on aurait pu faire qui
qui a été fait en irlande pour la
première des conventions citoyenne c'est
une sorte de mix
il y avait 100 personnes dont
33 députés 66 citoyens et un chairman qu
un président
et comme nous le disait la lnr lendemain
l'a77 spécialiste de la démocratie à
yale je suis comme à la radio que c'est
pour les gens qui sont arrivés en cours
je le redis
c'est pas idéal en terme de processus
démocratique c'est assez mieux que ça
soit que des citoyens mais dans un
premier temps quand c'est un processus
qui n'existe pas ça crée de la confiance
et ça crée quelque chose qui justement
n'a pas hyper bien fonctionner là c'est
à dire qu'il ya plein de députés qui se
sont sentis
dépossédés m6 heloir disant non mais
attends c'est notre rôle c'est à nous de
faire la loi dans ses citoyens une
aucune légitimité qu'est ce que c'est
que ça le tirage au sort donc là le fait
de les faire travailler ensemble en fait
ça prépare le terrain et ça veut dire
que une fois que les propositions sont
faites il ya déjà des députés qui les
ont et donc potentiellement ça va
directement au parlement sans encore une
fois repassé par ce filtre je pense que
c'est une chose qui peut qui mériterait
d'être essayée et qui créerait du lien
une autre chose c'est
je pense que si 2 vers parlé au
président je lui dirai ne fait pas de
promesses que vous ne pouvez pas tenir
c'est c'est pire c'est vraiment
un petit côté rocher de sisyphe cela
je sais que vous y arrive à jamais et
quand même il faut essayer
c'est vrai dire que d'une certaine
manière il vaut mieux avoir un
engagement un tout petit peu moins
important mais le tenir et que tout le
monde puisse se rendre compte qu'il a
été tenu parce que ça en fait ça crée un
socle de confiance qui permet dans un
système démocratique
éventuellement d'avancé et 2 et de faire
une étape ensuite avec quelque chose de
plus ambitieux là c'est mi figue mi
raisin parce qu'encore une fois on a
fait la démonstration que quelque chose
de vraiment super mais pour toute une
partie des gens en fait c'est juste
la manifestation de plus que que voilà
que les politiques sont des escrocs
qu'ils tiennent jamais leurs paroles de
toute façon on savait bien
et c'est pas génial dans un monde où le
populisme a tendance à exploser la
démocratie est de plus en plus faible
c'est pas super et du coup la prochaine
étape c'est quoi c'est à dire on prend
les mêmes et on recommence justement
surtout pas les mêmes on en prend en
sens en outre tiré au sort les mélanges
avec 50 députés et en cadence la sq la
prochaine étape pour moi c'est parce que
c'est un processus permanent c'est à
dire qu'on voit bien que d'abord la loi
qui a été votée reste partiel par
rapport à l'ensemble des choses à faire
ensuite le nombre de gens qui ont un peu
amélioré leur connaissance du problème à
traiter dans la population dans son
ensemble parce que en fait les citoyens
qui sont passés par cette convention ils
ont créé un écart très fort par rapport
à l'or alors concitoyens sur la
compréhension du problème quand je
prends la balle et j'ai presque oui
effectivement il faut pas buté sur des
problèmes techniques c'est toujours un
peu désagréable
on ne sait pas le nombre de grandes
théories qui ont buté sur l'épreuve de
câbles et alors
et
c'est un peu décousu dans les questions
et donc il y en a eu quand même qui et
comment combler au moment où les
citoyens font part de leur copie
cet écart qui s'est creusée par la force
des choses sur la compréhension du
problème à traiter entre eux et le reste
de la population qui doit être convaincu
des mesures donc ça c'est un sujet
facile et un deuxième sujet c'est what
next parce que maintenant que de toute
façon le problème n'a pas été vraiment
traiter ce qu'on a voté une loi elle est
partielle par rapport à l'ensemble des
choses qu'il faudrait faire sur un
certain nombre de mesures elle est
évident par rapport à des choses qui
sont fondées et qui ont été et qui ont
été proposées donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
on recommence jusqu'à ce que ça marche
au fait qu'ils ont fait pour moi la
première des choses c'est qu'il faudrait
donner une une existence
institutionnelle à ce type de processus
de démocratie délibérative voire même de
démocratie directe comme je le disais
maintenant donc ça serait plus important
pour toi que m avait à nouveau dans
l'article 1er de la constitution je sais
pas quoi et de s'en remettre aux juges
en disant avec un peu de chance il
interprètera sa dans le bon sens moi je
pense qu'il faudrait créer un rique
délibératif
citoyenne qui passe ensuite un système
délibérative et il me semble que ensuite
la façon dont la délibération de ce
produit avec qui est ce que c'est que
des citoyens tirés au sort est-ce que
c'est dans un premier temps des citoyens
mélangés avec des élus ça ça mérite
d'être discuté et je pense que ça dépend
des contextes et que ça dépend des
contextes encore une fois de confiance
que les citoyens ont dans leurs élus que
les élus ont dans ce type de processus
et envoyait confiance allaient un peu
émoussé donc à mon avis ce serait une
étape intéressante et
il faudrait faire en sorte que
en fait ce que tu appelles le gap qu'il
faut combler entre les 150 et le reste
de la population théoriquement il se
comble de deux façons la première c'est
que ces processus là sont à ciel ouvert
justement pour que tout le monde puisse
s'y intéresser oui les gens les gens
n'ont pas le temps en pratique les élus
ont quand même été déchargé d'une partie
de leurs obligations quotidiennes et lui
dans un contact dans lequel ils ont eu
juste letemps ch ce qui est le propre de
tout le monde oui mais pour autant si
par exemple un certain nombre de gens
s'y intéresser même si c'est une
minorité si les médias s'y intéressaient
suffisamment pour faire des comptes
rendus réguliers de des petites des
petites bastide ce qui se passe de ce
qui se dit des idées fortes qui sortent
et c'est ça pourrait commencer à créer
un débat pour pourquoi est ce que ça ne
s'est pas produit cette fois là et
pourquoi c'est difficile que ça se
produise parce que la plupart des gens
ont vu cet exercice comme une façon pour
macron de se défausser de gagner du
temps de faire une pirouette de faire un
énième comité théodule donc globalement
les gens n'y croyaient pas ce qu'il
faudrait et c'est pour ça que c'est
important d'institutionnaliser ce genre
de processus c'est que comme en suisse
où tu sais que tu vas pouvoir
éventuellement être sollicités pour une
votation régulièrement et en général les
suisses votent trois ou quatre fois dans
l'année
si tu sais que ce genre de processus
existe et qui va vraiment aller à son
terme et qui va vraiment donner un
référendum non seulement tu t'intéresses
un peu au débat quoi si tu te dis ah oui
tiens dit non parce que tu sais encore
une fois tu sais que ça va servir à
quelque chose donc ça c'est la première
phase la deuxième phase c'est qu'une
fois que les conclusions ont été rendues
si ça fait l'objet d'une votation d'un
référendum à choix multiples une
campagne est donc dans cette campagne il
ya à nouveau de la discussion et là il
ya un rôle effectivement très important
des médias des pouvoirs publics pour
transmettre un certain nombre des
connaissances qui ont été transmises aux
150 typiquement le socle de
connaissances qui avait été fait pour
pour pour les citoyens la convention
semaine il faudrait que ce soit en ligne
d'accessoires dans une vidéo il perd
bien foutu corps a été validé par le
haut conseil pour le climat où le giec
aux jeunes ce qui pour qu'on soit sûr
que c'est de cesser de suffisamment
bonne qualité scientifiquement pour que
ça donne les bonnes
informations aux gens et qu'ensuite on
puisse faire voter les gens c'est très
différent de faire voter les gens dans
un référendum à choix multiples quand
ils ont eu la chance de s'intéresser aux
problèmes à travers leurs semblables qui
ont des gros si dans une délibération
puis dans une campagne où on a fait
l'effort de produire de la matière
pédagogique qui permet d'éclairer le
choix
alors le
la question des médias
est probablement un sujet une question
pour laquelle je mourrai sans avoir
trouvé la réponse parce que je n'ai
toujours pas compris je sais pas si toi
tu as une idée
sur la manière dont on arrivait à faire
en sorte que les médias soient un peu
plus contributif à l'éducation et un peu
moins dans un jeu relate des anecdotes
sans trop me poser enfin en gros allez
je vais être un peu méchant je parle de
ce qu'on prend de ce que je comprends et
pas nécessairement de ce qui est
important
et je sais pas si tu as des suggestions
parce que l'adhésion de la population à
un processus de cette nature l'intérêt
qu'ils trouvent dans les travaux etc
passent par les médias qui par un
psychologue lundi sont les seuls à
pouvoir faire la médiation de l'éthique
moyens ordinaires et les rendent pas
dans l'hémicycle n'avait pas eu des
visites guidées il ya des millions de
français qui sont passés voir ce qui se
passait
est-ce que là tu as tiré de cette
expérience aussi des idées dont tu te
dis voilà deux trois trucs qu'on
pourrait essayer pour faire en sorte que
les médias
je sais pas si je dois bien jouer un peu
plus leur rôle mais en tout cas on monte
un peu en garde à l'être je le dire sur
la diffusion des faits en fait il ya
deux
il ya deux axes je pense qu'il ya un axe
qui est de la médiation citoyenne dire
que on voit bien aujourd'hui le rôle
parfois pour le pire mais aussi parfois
pour le meilleur que des médiateurs que
son dd youtuber des influenceurs des ce
que tu veux peuvent jouer sur leur
chaîne youtube sur des réseaux sociaux
on vulgarise en un certain nombre de
sujets en allant regarder dans les
études scientifiques est donc l'un
potentiellement en allant participer à
ce genre de processus et en faisant des
vidéos super bien foutue qui donne le
sel et et là moi je suis assez étonné de
voir l'appétit qui a pour pour ces
chaînes qui sont quand même
ouais très pédagogique quoi c'est pas
vraiment de l'intervenante au sens
propre du terme et là aussi la dévotion
et le plaisir qu'un certain nombre de
ces youtuber influence un
je-ne-sais-quoi peuvent trouver à faire
cette médiation ils ont un vrai plaisir
à faire ça il ya trouvé de la
reconnaissance à le faire et donc ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui ce qui
se développe et qui est super parce que
là aussi on reste dans un espace
finalement citoyens d'intérêt général
ensuite pour les médias la grosse
problématique c'est que les médias comme
comme la plupart des entreprises sont
pris dans des mécaniques économique de
rentabilité et on voit bien aujourd'hui
que ce qui est terrible c'est que les
médias aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus
en ligne de moins en moins sur papier
donc de plus en plus tributaires des
réseaux sociaux pour que leurs articles
fonctionne et que et que leurs médias
soient lus et les réseaux sociaux pour
avoir parlé avec des troncs de l'ateq ya
pas si longtemps les réseaux sociaux ont
un algorithme qui favorisent aujourd'hui
en gros l'algorithme favorise les
publications qui ont le plus de
commentaires celles qui ont le plus de
commentaires c'est souvent celles qui
sont les plus polémiques
où les gens s'engueulent
ce qui a tendance justement à faire
monter le complotisme en tout cas d
encore des idées un peu farfelu et donc
si les médias veulent que l'algorithme
des réseaux sociaux
embarquent leurs articles et que ça ils
peuvent plus compter uniquement sur la
viralité organique comme on appelait ça
va c'est à dire que les fêtes les gens
aiment l'article et se partagent ils
doivent créer du débat donc être un peu
puis ta clique comme on dit avoir des
titres chocs être sur des sujets un peu
clivant
et ça c'est pas exactement ce dont on a
besoin justement pour avoir une société
démocratique apaisée où potentiellement
on peut se mettre tous autour d'une
table avoir une compréhension commune
d'un sujet et ensuite chercher une
réponse ajusté tous ensemble c'est même
le contraire donc aujourd'hui les médias
ont clairement tendance pour des raisons
économiques et des raisons d'algorithmes
à chercher la polarisation
plutôt qu'à chercher la concertation et
la délibération
jusqu'à pas une nouvelle
nom est d'ailleurs un aparté mais c'est
pas du tout une bonne nouvelle non plus
pour les élections parce que
on a tous suivi la sphère cambridge
analytica à l'époque il y avait cette
journaliste du guardian qui a qui a
suivi la faire pendant plus d'un an et
demi qui qui posait la question
comment est-ce qu'on peut être sûr qu'on
va être à nouveau capable d'avoir des
élections libres c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne
sont pas influencés
vraiment par des sociétés privées qui
sont capables de cibler les électeurs
grâce à toutes les dates à qui ont été
collectés pour pouvoir leur faire passer
des messages bien calibré et et orienter
leur vote comment est-ce qu'on peut être
sûr de ça et aujourd'hui la question est
de plus en plus prégnante parce que ce
que faisait cambridge annie analytique à
pourvoir encore une fois parler à ses
patrons de la tech dernièrement il ya
beaucoup de sociétés privées qui sont
capables de faire ça et encore mieux
qu'avant et clairement l'élection qui va
venir en france va se jouer énormément
sur les réseaux sociaux et va être
énormément tributaire du réglage des
algorithmes et donc ça malheureusement
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est
démocratiquement contrôlable et par les
sommes investies par les candidats pour
payer des sociétés privées justement
pour faire du microciblage et influencé
des électeurs et ça c'est que c'est
encore quelque chose qui est extrêmement
opaque et qui n'est pas du tout dans le
débat public encore l'impression que ça
se joue au débat à la télé dans les
meetings mais ça se joue beaucoup plus
maintenant sur le web que dans tous ces
endroits là et si on ne s'y intéresse
pas notre démocratie est encore plus en
danger
l'importance d'être présent alors
justement je vais je vais basculer sur
une question avec quelques minutes qui
nous reste
sur une quelque chose qui se rapproche
plus de ton milieu professionnel
ordinaire
je tends pas plus donc j'ai fait clic
simple clic j'ai l'impression mais c'est
je suis très prudent parce que je me
méfie toujours de mes impressions que
dans le monde des arts si les mares etc
le thème environnemental séduit
globalement beaucoup moins que le thème
social
alors j'ai éventuellement une hypothèse
mais je vais sûrement pas de la libre et
j'ai maintenant et j'aimerais savoir si
alors un du partage ce constat
et 2 tu as une explication
et alors ça fait un tout petit peu le
lien avec ce qu'on vient de dire parce
que c'est des personnages qui sont quand
même présents dans la sphère médiatique
et sur les réseaux sociaux parmi nous
alors pour le moment c'est vrai oui
c'est moins vrai dans la littérature ou
dans la littérature il ya une
c'est vers le haut ce qu'ils appellent
les class action
aux états unis ou dans le monde anglo
saxon et même là dans l'est
je n'allais pas nécessairement du fond
je parlais du militantisme des individus
ou par individu
tu vois par exemple grande à tutu prend
à l'époque où ça passait un plateau de
qui veut gagner des millions spécial
associations et des filets tout un tas
de l'association pour
l'éducation les gens défavorisés
l'handicapé c'est pourquoi la cause
environnementale était très peu
représentées et dans les gens qui
s'expriment
sur ce qu'il faudrait changer dans le
monde
c'est quand même beaucoup plus fréquent
d'avoir des gens dans le monde du
spectacle qui s'expriment sur la misère
sociale donc je peux en train de faire
un jugement de valeur en dix ans et
marché mondial juge constate et la
question et des sk est ce que tu as une
explication à ça moi je t'avoue que je
trouve que c'est de plus en plus quand
même dire que moi je vois de plus en
plus d'artistes la situation en train
d'organiser de faire un podcast avec
avec plein d'acteurs français sur la
capelle animalia sur le
d'extinction des espèces août à
guillaume gallienne isabelle adjani
françois civil
ça m'arrive régulièrement de faire des
trucs à que marion cotillard avec
avec juliette binoche là il ya eu cette
sélection au festival de cannes cinéma
pour le climat où il y avait un maïga
qui avait fait un film où il y avait le
gard elles donc
ça vient c'est un mis du temps à venir
là clairement ça vient vrai jeu il était
question que j'organise un conte un
grand concert et que france 2 donc les
artistes de la musique étaient tous
prêts à venir aussi failli saillie
comprennent que c'est l'enjeu du siècle
donc il va falloir en parler et ça a été
long et moi j'ai mal compris la question
mais c'est aussi quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est que pendant
longtemps
les scénaristes les réalisateurs sont
absolument pas saisi du sujet et ne
savait pas comment raconter des
histoires là dessus
donc quelques films et le jour d'après
une catastrophe il ya eu avatar avec une
tentative justement d'avoir la question
écologique un peu en creux est un mais
sinon très peu de choses comme s'il
savait pas par où la trappe et qu'ils
avaient peur d'être moralisateur qu'il
avait peur de faire des trucs à ta thèse
et et là aussi c'est en train de venir
est ce que vous êtes en train devenir
plus par la littérature oui commencé à
beaucoup de romans qui qui qui se
saisissent du sujet et donc
mécaniquement le cinéma parce que le
cinéma va beaucoup plus hachée dans les
lions donc non moi je vois un vrai
basculement depuis
deux trois ans quoi est bon dans le
reste de la société parce que moi
j'avais une hypothèse alors un pouvoir
pour taquine mais qui était de dire le
monde du spectacle est quand même un
monde tout le monde connaît l'expression
la vie de jet setteur ou quand on a
réussi en fait ça va avec un deuil une
aisance matérielle j'ai envie de dire
ostentatoire ou dans des grosses
bagnoles 2 pd1b du champagne j'ai pas
encore et qu'il est compliqué de mariée
avec une un discours public invitant à
la modération parce que la préservation
de l'environnement il ya quand même une
grosse composent 30 modération et
chapeau ils étaient dans le discours
public qu'on doit te dire est ce que
c'est une des causes ça selon toi ou ou
pas tant ça existe chez un certain
moment effectivement 2
d'artistes qui disent non mais moi je
n'ai pas de leçon à donner on peut
effectivement de se faire attaquer là
dessus et ça existe beaucoup chez des
influenceurs des youtuber c'est un des
gens ont suivi par des millions de gens
qui font du placement de produit et qui
sont réticents parce qu'ils se disent je
vais me faire me perds clash et sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que
moi je peux pas trop de l'ouvrir quoi et
donc il a fallu aussi
il a fallu aller en chercher
quelques-uns dix ans mais 10 clubs
indiquent que moi même je n'arrive pas
même j'y suis pas du tout mais mais je
vois bien qu'il faut qu'on dirait quoi
et moi le premier
et donc y en a qui le font mais qu'il
faut mais qui s'en prennent plein la
figure quand même je sais que maintien
elles sont peut-être s'en prend
régulièrement dès qu'on la voit dans une
pub dior dans un aéroport avec
moi enfin moi aussi un signe un
mois on vient me dire mais vous et que
vous avez fait pour fait votre film
j'étais en trottinette vous est pris
l'avion vous êtes un hypocrite ou sa
façon il
faut faire comme greta
c'est plus long pour les films ça ça
prend plusieurs années ah oui ça c'est
quoi la basse et plus long pour tous
c'est clair que c'est une des
difficultés de la transformation du
monde qui nous attend c'est qu'en fait
l'énergie si une tente du salut est visé
ça nous a brisé sa nouvelle a donné la
vitesse vous a tout donné et c'est clair
que de faire avec 100 ou enfin de faire
avec moi ou beaucoup moins c'est à un
moment ou à devoir je sais pas s'il faut
passer mais il ya quelque chose de ça je
suis allé cet été à venise en voiture
électrique dire que c'était pas comme y
aller en avion
[Rires]
mais t'as vu plus de paysages le visage
maintenant le réseau de bornes de
recharge pour moi je suis allé à
stockholm en train et j'en garde un
excellent souvenir oui moi si j'étais
fier des déplacements devient voyage
causé
bon ok les souvenirs d'anciens
combattants sont peut-être pour un autre
jour puisque total la sncf il devions
partir à l'heure exhalons arriver à leur
merci énormément doit être traité à ce
petit exercice
j'espère que les gens qui nous ont
regardés on a pris quelques chemins en
tout cas moi j'ai appris un certain de
trucs donc ça
au moins content pour ça après des trucs
là je suis fier de
tout âge
voilà et bien nous allons remettre non
pas notre mandat en jeu mais notre
parole à madame loyal
puisque je crois que c'est à emma qui
revient prononcer les mots de conclusion
oui un oedème loyal magali
deux
passionnants
beaucoup de sujets a exploré en tout cas
sachez que vous avez été plus de 1600
entre nous mais facebook à nous suivre
en live et que cette vidéo sera mise en
ligne sur la chaîne youtube de deux
sites project et dans les prés
alors effectivement on a parlé beaucoup
de de mobilisation citoyenne de rouages
de la démocratie mais nous protège
chiffres pour continuer à travailler
aussi sur le fond sur les mesures sur ce
qui doit être mis en place notamment que
le prochain quinquennat est donc dans
les semaines à venir dans les mois à
venir on a un certain nombre de
publication de rapports sectoriels
notamment le rapport de la culture tout
début décembre pour justement présenté
les priorités pour des cas redonné la
société et on a un live un webinaire dès
demain soir donc à 18h même endroit sur
facebook et ce sera un autre zoom pour
la résidence des territoires quelles
sont les actions à mettre en oeuvre au
niveau local à retrouver demain soir et
magali et on est prêt vous avez aussi de
belles actualité le port oui et bien
dans la foulée du live de chiffres de
demain à 18 heures on en a aussi un à 19
heures avec paloma moritz qui notre
rédac'chef et qui est aussi responsable
du pôle écologique chez blast avec
gilles boeuf qui est ancien directeur du
muséum d'histoire naturelle gilles moyne
le directeur du centre athénas et
adelaïde charrier l'objectif ça va être
de parler de notre nouvelle campagne qui
s'appelle zones sauvages devenait
gardiens de la nature et qui a comme je
le disais en début de séance objectif à
faire vraiment monter ce sujet de la
biodiversité au même pardon un même
niveau que celui du climat donc vraiment
faire comprendre les enjeux de la
sixième extinction de masse le deuxième
est en jeu c'est d'émerveiller sur le
vivant autour de soi et en fait pour ça
on a gagné un peu les choses en
proposant un test animal totem et des
actions pour protéger son animal totem
parmi treize animaux en voie de
disparition en france et on parlait des
youtuber tout à l'heure des influenceurs
ça c'est vraiment une des composantes de
notre campagne parce que c'est ce qui
nous permet d'aller toucher la jeunesse
là où elle est à savoir sur les réseaux
sociaux instagram aujourd'hui tik tok
est bien moins facebook qu'avant et
surtout de créer un effet de pédagogie
inversé c'est à dire que les jeunes eux
mêmes vont aller toucher leurs parents
et leurs grands-parents voilà donc vous
êtes bienvenu en zone sauvage demain à
19 heures
voilà peut-être que le prochain live en
préciser les jambes à
la plus en plus jeunes nous tue c'est
donc oui ça c'est malheureusement ce qui
nous as qui finit un jour par nous
arriver à tous c'est à dire que à un
moment le vieillissement est un
rajeunissement
pas nécessairement pour le meilleur
bon
et bien encore merci merci à toi cyril
merci à tout le monde et à bientôt eh
bien oui au revoir